欢迎各位苏聆今天这期摆车圈说我是三刀。
今天这期节目咱们来聊一聊北京车展。
今天是4月25号，大家听到节目应该是到4月26号了。
今天又是比较晚的去录节目。
我那是4月24号其实就已经当天晚上回到南京。
那么当天车展其实差不多在4点半5点的样子就已经陆陆续续闭管了。
晚上9点的飞机，北京车展大家都如果参加过你就知道其实去展馆还算比较容易。
打个车的话，你不能到展馆门口下，你得要在旁边的路口然后再慢慢的走过去，
因为那边是有交通管制。
那么如果说是坐地铁的话，其实也还好，走的也不是特别的远。
但是如果说你要是在宽药闭管的时候离开展馆的话，
那你就会遇到非常痛苦的一件事情，特别是像我赶飞机。
首先打车的话在现场叫车差不多，
你会看到软件上显示有200多人同时在排队。
所以这两天如果你要是去看北京车展的话，
你能不在闭管的时间段大概在4点半到5点半左右，
你能这个时间段不要出来，那是最好的。
就是你尽早走，或者你干脆就在周边在逛一逛，
你再尽晚走，或者说你就去集地铁，再坐个两三站然后再打车。
所以这是一点小经验。
这次的北京车展很有意思，
今天我们主要想聊一聊我逛完北京车展之后的一些思考。
这个思考对大家有什么帮助呢？
我觉得几点，第一个呢，如果说你是车迷，
我觉得你去逛展的时候，你大概就会有一个思路，
哪些是重点要看的，哪些我觉得可看可不看，
因为这个整馆实在是太大，车实在是太多。
那么第二个呢，就是如果你要想买车，
那么今天这些节目你听完之后，
应该对你买车的思路会有一些变化，
或者说会有一些这种，也可以说是启发吧，
因为我觉得今年北京车展跟往年真的不太一样，
不仅仅是跟往年的北京车展了，
大家都知道北京车展上海车展是轮流的嘛，
上一次北京车展是2024年对吧，
那么这次的车展因为规模特别大，
那么我作为这个媒体来讲的话，
一整天你要想把它全部完完整整的都逛完，
然后把每一个细节都能掌握到非常非常难，
所以今天这些节目呢，我觉得分几个部分啊，
是首先就是今年的这个北京车展跟往年的最大的差别是什么，
我的感受就是最明显的一些这种体验不一样的地方，
我想跟大家去分享一下，
那么第二一个就是我另几个重点，
就是我感觉今天我看到的包括在新车这一块啊，
包括在技术这一块的一些变化，
跟大家来聊一聊，
其实今年的北京车展呢规模大到什么程度，
我可以这么讲啊，
今年是跟2024年的北京车展比的话，
翻了将近一倍的这个展出面积，
2024年的话它展出面积是22万平米，
那么今年是38万平米，
那么为什么呢，
是因为它今年是把新展馆跟老展馆啊，
它把它合二为一了，
什么意思呢，就是你往年如果是从这个比方说新馆到老馆，
或者老馆到新馆，
那么你需要有个百度车啊，
百度过去，
但是一般人不会这么百度，
为什么呢，
因为它以前是把这个零部件，
或者说是其他的一些跟新车无关的，
它是放在另外一个馆啊，
或者说是放在新馆的边上啊，
反正就是你逛新车归逛新车，
你如果不逛新车的话，
那么你想逛其他的一些比方说汽车零部件啊，
或者是以前其实还有一些汽车文化展，
包括一些改装，
还有包括一些这种汽车相关的一些技术展示，
那都不在我们讲的就是整车的展馆里面，
但是今年呢是把两者融二为一了，
什么意思呢，
就是你在新车的展馆里面也能看到零部件的展台，
那么在零部件的展馆里面啊，
其实都融在一起了，
零部件展馆也能看到新车，
当然了它也有专门的就是这个汽车的零部件供应商的展馆，
那有人肯定要讲了说，
那这个汽车零部件我为什么要看呢，
那你这么想啊，
如果说它是一个比方说手机的厂商，
它做展览，
那么你如果是逛了这个苹果手机的展台，
Vivo的OPPO的华为的小米的，
你都逛了一圈之后，
你想不想去逛一逛比方说这个芯片的展台，
你想不想去逛一逛这种比方说屏幕的展台，
金通方的最新的屏幕的技术啊，
然后包括三星啊，
对不对，
那你想不想逛一逛摄像头的展台，
你也想看一看，
就比方说莱卡或者是蔡司啊，
或者是他们这个合作的一些摄像头，
他们今后在手机上面会用什么样最新的技术，
你想不想逛，
其实你买手机最核心的不就是看这三样东西吗，
所以今年你会发现，
汽车的零部件的供应商从幕后现在走到台前，
而且是非常非常的明显，
而且我感觉是官方也是想引导大家，
这些零部件的供应商走到台前来，
那么大的一些品牌大家都熟悉的像林德时代啊这些对吧，
那么还有一些可能你没有听过名字，
可是你到展台上逛了一圈，
你再去了解一下你会发现，
哦哦哦原来这个品牌，
哦原来那个车，
哦原来这个车全都是用你们家的东西啊，
所以我觉得很有意思，
北京车展我个人感觉啊你一天逛不完，
如果你是自身车米或者说你像我刚刚讲的，
你除了逛新车，
你还想再去看一看新车背后的这些供应商，
那我觉得你至少是花两天时间，
你不一定说第一天第二天嘛你可以错开来，
对不对有些人平时上班比较忙，
他只有周末，
你可以比方说上班你请一天假，
或者说是周末两天连续看都是可以的，
那么今年一共是17个馆，
一共是1451台展车，
全球首发的新车有181台，
概念车一共是71台，
概念车呢我估计你要如果是到了普通观众日，
你不一定能看得到，
那么跟大家简单讲一下，
因为我前两天做了一个短视频，
在网上反小还蛮好的，
就是我解释了一下媒体日，
专业观众日和普通的观众日有什么区别，
那么其实简单来讲的话，
媒体日就是用来报道的，
就是媒体日的两天24跟25号，
从头到尾全是发布会，
这两天时间这一次一共是，
我看统计下来发了有200多场的新闻发布会，
你想一想200多场什么概念，
那就是这家结束内加上，
这家结束内加上嘛，
那么在这个展馆里面呢，
它会有个要求，
它不像有一些地方的车展，
就它可能会两场发布会同时进行，
那展馆里面的声音就会特别的吵对吧，
这家的音响的声音小了，
那家声音就大，
应该这么讲，
这家的声音大，
那家声音更大，
对不对，最后就是两家各自都听不到对方的声音，
那以前特别的乱，
但是北京车展这种国际车展是不会干这个事情的，
绝对不可能这么干，
他们一般都是会要求，
就是必须前一家结束，
比方说给你安排到几点几分，
你一分钟都不能抄，
你比方说9点到9点20分，
那9点20分结束之后，
9点25分就是下一个品牌，
开始进行发布会，
它是连着发的，
所以我曾经也跟大家讲，
就是如果你要是想在媒体日去看车的话，
上午你基本上看不到什么车，
因为基本上午，
就是你去得早的话，
9点钟进场，
很多的首发新车全部是用黑布包着的，
是整个的就盖在上面，
你等它发布会结束之后，
这个展车才能由媒体来进行拍摄，
而有一些车型，
它毕竟是涉及到还没上市，
可能要到明年或者今年下半年，
它可能会把它的车窗玻璃贴成黑色，
或者说它会把它围起来，
围起来就不让普通媒体，
或者叫没有预约的媒体吧，
不能上车看，
但是你要如果预约了，
那你就可以去到展台上去看车，
你比如说像今年的这个宝马的新世代的RX3，
它就是这样子的，
它虽然说展台上有差不多五辆吧，
四辆还是五辆，
但是都不让媒体进去看，
你只有预约，
你才能在这个时间点，
你进去拍摄，
每个人的时间都是固定的，
所以大概是这么个情况，
那么媒体日是这样的，
就你要注册，
你才能进去看，
它是不卖票的，
那么到了这个专业观众日呢，
专业观众日有几点，
第一个呢就是，
如果从车的角度来讲的话，
专业观众日一般情况下，
概念车可能还没车，
然后概念车包括那种首发的一些，
这种明年要上的，
或者说是还没上市的新车，
它还没撤掉，
你还能看到，
而且现场呢它基本没有销售，
不叫基本，
它就是没有销售，
现场都是厂家的一些，
安排的专业的讲师，
或者是甚至有些工程师，
你要是运气好，
你还能遇到包括这个车型的，
这个主导的人员，
你可以在现场跟他进行交流，
专业观众日，
那首先你也得专业啊，
对吧,
你也得问出一些专业的问题啊，
他不卖车，
那么同时呢，
专业观众日更多的是什么，
是做一些比方说，
这个就是上下游的一些对接的，
这种叫采销会啊，
你可以理解为，
或者说是，
这种行业的分会，
所以专业观众日更多的是，
你比方说花了100块钱，
你去了你交交朋友，
你比方说你是这个上游的供应商，
你跟那个其他的跟你相关的一些生意伙伴，
发发名片，
加加微信，
交交朋友，
开开会，
对吧,
你听一听行业的一些趋势，
然后呢，
这个感受一下这个行业的氛围，
所以专业观众日的，
其实我觉得它不是贵50块钱嘛，
我觉得这50块钱贵的，
对于普通消费者来讲的话，
你可能就是，
你会肯定是不会参加嘛，
你可能就是多看一些车吧，
有些概念车它还没撤掉，
那么到了普通观众日的话，
那基本上，
展台上放的都是要卖的车，
所以它一般情况下是，
不会放概念车，
甚至于那些还没上市的一些车型，
就是你可能之前看到，
有些车评人已经是静态的盆拍，
静态拍摄已经拍完了，
然后动态施加，
甚至你也看到视频，
可是车没上市，
那这些车因为它，
它不是再瘦的，
它应该都会撤掉，
那么换回来的车就全部都是，
目前再瘦的车型，
那么剩下来这几天，
就主要是以卖车为主，
所以简单讲一下，
就是有些人可能还没买票，
对吧,
那么到底什么叫做媒体日，
什么叫做专业观众日，
什么叫做普通观众日，
那这基本上就讲完了，
那么今年这个车展的规模，
可以说是全球对大，
这个一点不夸张，
这绝对就是全球对大，
而且如果你要是去看一些海外的新闻，
你会发现，
其实海外的车展这两年是比较落魄，
而且海外的车展其实这两年，
也是需要中国的车去成厂子，
所以不管是欧洲的车展也好，
当然了，
美国就可能有点特殊情况，
对吧,
美国咱不算，
你包括在中东有些车展，
那基本都是新能源唱主导，
那新能源就不用说了，
那肯定是中国品牌唱主导，
所以大体上，
今年的北京车展就是这么个概念，
那么我们汽车媒体同行，
很多在微博上也晒过说，
我走了四万步，
我走了三万步，
对吧,
那今年我是带了我一个粉丝一起去，
这个粉丝应该在听我的节目，
这粉丝最后是走了多少步，
他应该是走了三万多，
将近四万步，
是吧,
因为我来的比较晚，
我上午其实还有一片稿子在赶，
所以我是中午到的，
有人讲说三刀，
你怎么会中午才到北京车展，
其实对于我来讲，
我今年的北京车展的思路是这样的，
我只去感受，
只去看我觉得重点的车型，
那么其他的我就不去一一的，
像往年那种，
说我要去现场赶视频，
我要去拍，
其实当同志化的内容，
在同一时间就是无限量的供应的时候，
它是没有流量的，
而且无限量供应的时候，
它的质量会变得很差，
它的信息的，
不过接收的人来讲的话，
它其实更多的是无效信息，
说白了，
你其实上个董车地，
上个汽车之家，
你基本上想看的一些车型，
看的就已经很全了，
然后你再去定向的，
在一些短视频频台，
或者是图文平台上搜一下，
那你对这个车的基本信息，
已经非常非常了解了，
所以今年我觉得，
就这么赶的一个车展，
而且这么大型的一个车展，
你要想在这里面去抓取一些，
有用的信息，
制作一些高质量的内容，
还是比较难的，
所以我不如就干脆，
诚下心来去试一试，
我想试的重点车型，
感受一下这个行业的发展趋势，
然后等我以后，
对吧,
我把我这些想法，
沉寂下来，
就沉淀下来之后，
我再放到我的播客节目里面，
放在我的一些视频节目里面，
这样的话就会有更多的，
亲身的感受，
我是这么想的，
那么今年其实，
这个北京车展，
表面上看是，
很多的汽车爱好者，
对吧,
这么多的车子，
我就非常开心，
是一个狂欢，
但实际上，
它是新车发布的一个集中秀场，
只要你真正地要走进去，
你会发现，
其实北京车展已经不只是看，
看这个新车了，
而是看中国汽车产业的一次，
集体的体检，
这个怎么讲的，
你可以这么讲嘛，
为什么叫体检？
就是,
外行是看热闹，
内行是看病造，
有人听到病造这个词，
可能不太吉利，
那确实是这样子的，
就是,
你看产品，
那我可能看到是焦虑，
你看的是展台，
我看到的可能是话语权，
和权力的一些变化，
真的非常非常的明显，
我们举个例子，
我们就举两个例子，
以前是合资品牌，
包括BBA,
他们是有定价权，
是有话语权的，
那么大家都知道，
这两年新能源，
对吧,
不管是定价权，
还是话语权，
是越来越大，
那么以前是，
你看一辆车，
首先你要认品牌，
对不对，
你只认合资，
或者说你只认比阿迪，
或者怎样，
但是今年你会发现，
你去看新能源车，
你基本上坐上车，
第一句话你会怎么问，
你说,
哎你这个车机芯片，
你说我们用的是8295的，
你觉得8295还行，
你们支架用的是哪家的，
我们支架用的是摩满塔，
最新的R6R7的大模型，
R6R7,
还行,
你们家现在，
比如说三电系统，
电池用的哪家的，
电池我们家用的零德时代，
零德时代还行，
如果他跟你讲说，
我们家电池是零德时代，
或者是新旺达，
你们家用的新旺达，
新旺达我不要，
我不考虑，
所以你会发现个什么问题，
就是真正的话语权，
他的迭代，
已经跟以前完全不一样，
就你选车的方式，
前一末画的，
就是把他的供应链，
或者说是他的这种供应商的品牌，
放到了第一位，
而不是这个车的品牌，
是不是这么个概念，
所以你看那个这两年，
这个半价理想，
这个零跑为什么销量那么好，
其实零跑我觉得吃的也是这个红利，
就是体系化的这个红利，
你现在再不在意，
他是零跑啊，
不在意啊，
欣骗我的谁呢，
对吧,
包括支架的算力是多少呀，
然后你整体的，
包括电池电信用的是谁家的，
你只要把这个控制好，
基本上这台车大体上的，
你觉得他的核心的体验，
应该是不会有什么差别的，
对吧,
特别是之前买过新的原车的人，
再去买第二辆，
他其实反而对于品牌的，
这种怎么讲的，
就是这种偏爱，
或者说是这种痴迷，
程度就越来越小了，
他就去妹了，
就像以前没买过BBA的，
买完之后就去妹了，
是不是，
那么今年其实我觉得，
更多的人其实看的是什么，
其实看的是，
不是网上讲的那些，
什么摇摇领先，
什么各种新的概念，
什么智能中端，
什么生态必还，
不看这些东西了，
大家逛车展逛三圈，
逛两圈逛完之后，
其实现在看的就是，
脑子里面想的是什么，
AI，大模型，
支架800V5C,。
什么激光雷达，
固态雷达，
什么,
大家其实常听来听去，
你们家三颗，
他们家六颗，
对不对，
你看来看去就是这些东西，
其实你脑子里面，
你要是买新能源，
你可能对于各种，
我刚刚提到的这些词语，
它背后，
设计到就在车上的一些功能展示，
包括你的体验，
就是都是你想要去，
真正去感受到的，
你可能最终买单是为这些东西去买单，
所以今年的北京车展，
我觉得很有意思的地方，
不是说它的规模有多大，
而是它到底想要表达什么，
它到底想要让你去体验到什么，
这届车展表面上是全球之罪，
其实背后有很多的车企的焦虑，
也有很多车企的野心，
每个品牌都想用最大的声量告诉你，
但这个声量不是把那个喇叭的声音开大，
而是它想用它的各种各样的形式表现给你看，
想要告诉你，告诉同行，告诉投资人，
告诉各种全世界的经销商，
我还活着我没有掉队，
我还有各种各样的黑科技，
各种各样的技术，
我还能讲各种各样的故事，
但是你仔细听其实每个人讲的故事，
它背后它都有一个问题，
就是这个汽车，
它未来的五年、十年，
甚至更久，
它到底被谁去重新定义？
你仔细想一想，
因为你要能定义这个未来大家买车的这么一个概念，
其实你就能掌握话语权，
掌握定价权，
这个非常的关键，
那这个问题其实理解起来也很简单，
汽车它就是汽车，
对不对，
但是汽车它又不是汽车，
为什么这么讲呢？
就是以前我们讲汽车讲的是三大件，
就把什么变速箱发动机底盘，
说这个是灵魂，
那么现在已经不买油车了嘛，
大家很多都是买新能源了，
那么买新能源的话，
大家比什么呢？
电池，电机，续航，
但是再往后你会发现，
那智能化又来了，
智能化来了以后，
车子就变成一个移动中端，
所以今年北京车站你会发现，
那么它不仅仅是移动中端，
它也不仅仅是交通工具，
它被定义成一个什么？
它更像是个机器人，
它像是一个由数据啊，
算法啊，
芯片啊，
电池啊，
A啊,
还有很多的供应链，
它共同编织出来的一套，
这种,
怎么讲呢？
生态的体系，
其实我一直有一个很大胆的想法，
我觉得今后你不要问哪个品牌死，
哪个品牌活，
或者哪一家车请能活多久，
我觉得今后，
它只会像手机一样，
分成安卓阵营和苹果阵营，
其实现在慢慢的已经出现这种情况了，
你比如说，
华为是一套自己的这个比较封闭的生态，
对吧,
华为都是我不造车，
我去服务汽车企业，
让很多人跟华为去合作，
其实你一旦要是合作，
你会发现，
你进入到了华为的一套封闭的体系里面，
红萌的这套体系，
那么除了华为以外，
车企里面有一家也很像，
也就是做封闭体系的，
就是比亚迪，
比亚迪不仅仅是他们家的，
不管是质价也好，
还是车机也好，
包括它的整个的制造，
甚至包括芯片全是自己造，
是不是，
所以这两家是偏封闭的生态体系的，
那么还有更多的就是开放式的，
就是跟什么摩摩塔合作，
跟林德合作，
跟各种各样的合作，
那么因此，
在汽车这个产业里面，
今后我估猜，
它可能会从它的生态，
从它的座舱，
就从座舱的这套系统开始，
它就会分成两到三个阵营，
最多最多不会超过三个阵营，
所以今后哪怕汽车品牌它活下来了，
但是它的座舱，
它的这个整个生态，
肯定是死掉一大片，
不可能像现在的这个市场上，
说有那么多不同的车机，
那么多不同的生态，
那么多不同的，
这个什么智能驾驶的方案，
不可能，
今后就那么两三家，
就那么两三家，
我觉得不会有那么多的，
今后应该是由座舱来定义，
谁跟谁站在一个同盟里面，
是由包括智驾也好，
智能座舱也好，
就是他们统一成一个生态，
包括你们家的智能家居，
全部统一成一个生态，
所以你可以把大家理解为是一个智能中段，
或者说是一个，
就类似于像，
我们之前讲机器人叫狙生智能嘛，
它就是一个没有手没有脚，
可以在路上跑的这样的一个狙生智能，
所以今后我觉得是，
就像安卓手机跟苹果手机一样，
就分两到三个，
这样的一套生态体系，
不会再多了，
绝对不会再多了，
我们继续往下聊，
就这次北京车展，
其实我觉得，
你要如果去看完之后，
你再回来去跟人聊说，
我今天看到一辆车，
零百加速有多快，
发动机有多么的震撼，
我觉得可能性不大，
你包括你也不会跟人家讲说，
我看到一辆车，
设计的多么经验，
内饰多么的漂亮，
也可能性不大，
你更多的回来，
还是会去聊一些，
跟智能化相关的东西，
跟车机上的一些，
什么激光雷达，
车机芯片相关的一些东西，
其实逛车展逻辑非常的清晰，
主场馆是看整车的，
包括新能源的品牌，
自助品牌，
包括奥迪一些盒子品牌，
那么如果你还有时间，
我刚刚前面讲的，
零部件的供应商的展台是一定要去看的，
那么这个展台，
以前是在另外一个展区，
但是现在是融合到一起，
你不要认为说，
今年的北京车展的重头戏，
或者主角式新车，
其实真不是，
今年你要如果多去逛一逛，
这些供应商的展台，
你可能收获，
比你去看新车，
还要更多，
而这些展台上的这些公司的名字，
很多人都根本叫不出来，
因为你去买车，
你只认这些汽车的，
就整车厂的品牌嘛，
对不对，
你叫不出来，
但是你去问一问，
你这家芯片的公司，
它是供哪家，
那家雷达的公司，
供哪家，
这家的电池公司，
包括智能驾驶方案的公司，
他们现在其实占的这些通道啊，
包括位置啊，
我觉得真的还是有的非常非常的不错，
有的是跟奔驰爱在一起的，
有的是跟鸿蒙智行爱在一起的，
有的是跟，
就是像我们了解的像大众丰田啊，
都是非常大的展厅，
旁边就跟着就是这些供应商，
所以今年我觉得，
这个不再是当年，
我们讲华语拳，
全部在主机场，
全在整车这个车旗，
就像车旗选飞一样啊，
就是他们永远站在台前，
然后供应店站在台后，
今年是有一点，
这个供应商登机的感觉，
供应商站在前面了，
我给你平起平坐了，
是不是，
你的话，
平起平坐的概念就是，
你的话语拳没有以前那么大了，
我现在有更多的话语拳，
而且消费者不一定认你，
消费者是任务，
所以讲来讲去，
其实现在就跟，
手机行业真的是越来越像了，
你想想看十几年前，
可能都不止十几年前，
可能二十年前了，
大家如果是买手机，
那种键盘机的话，
你可能看的就是，
洛基亚，
摩托罗拉，
艾利兴，
大家还记得艾利兴吗，
你就,
只要是个牌子就行了，
我只在这个牌子里面去选，
各种不同的型号，
但是现在不是了，
现在我觉得很多的一些朋友，
除非你们家所有的这些家用电器，
都是跟他一个生态的，
你可能说，
我就只选这个手机品牌，
那么除此之外，
像我这种家里面没有，
去用各种什么样，
什么华为的生态，
小米的生态，
所以我对于华为跟小米，
我没有任何的，
这种,
怎么讲呢，
就是非他不买的念想，
我都可以买，
我可以用苹果手机，
我也可以用安卓手机，
微博OPPO也可以，
小米华为也都是OK的，
我只要觉得说这台车，
不是这台车，
这个手机在某一方面，
解决了我的痛点，
那我就可以用它，
你比如说我现在有个折叠屏，
那我这个折叠屏是微博的，
其实我根本就无所谓是微博的，
还是华为的折叠屏，
我无非用的就是它最核心那个功能，
左边跟右边可以同开两个APP，
所以当我去发微博的时候，
我可以把右边的，
相关的文字复制到左边，
我也可以把右边的图片，
直接拖到左边去发微博，
非常的方便，
这个功能可以说，
占到我折叠屏手机90%的使用的环境，
因为我的折叠屏手机很少是不打开的，
因为我不打开的状态下，
其实那我不如用我的iPhone了，
对不对，
但是我要如果它打开的话，
它这个功能iPhone是根本就用不了，
iPhone没有这个功能，
哪怕iPhone后面出折叠屏，
我估计两个软件同开，
去拖拉照片可能是可以的，
但是,
我不知道它对于这个两个软件之间的数据打通，
做的怎么样，
如果说它要讲究什么隐私，
讲究一些什么软件跟或者图片的版权，
或者怎样，
那它要如果禁止这个功能，
就像苹果到今天都没有微信的双开，
那么安卓手机微信双开也是我的刚需嘛，
当然了，
当然不是折叠屏也可以，
但是折叠屏对我最大的用处，
就是从A软件拖一张照片到B软件直接发布，
因为我是要经常发铁的人，
我要经常去做内容的人，
包括去看沃尔勒文党看PPT，
这里屏一打开，
哇，那是非常的爽，
对不对，
还有就是看视频，
那就是另当别论了，
这看视频我用的比较少，
这个比较尴尬，
因为我看视频一般都是在高铁跟飞机上，
因为我平时都比较忙，
就是坐飞机坐高铁这个时间，
没事可干，
那就看视频，
但是我看视频呢，
我买了一个手机支架，
大家如果看我的微博应该能看到，
我是把它架在那个飞机或者是高铁，
前排座椅靠背上面的那个小桌板，
我是把它架在那上面，
那是一个专门的，
就是夹在小桌板上面的支架，
非常好用，
但是那有个问题点就是，
我只有把折叠屏合上，
我才能用那个支架，
我不能把折叠屏打开然后用，
所以就很尴尬，
所以我看视频大部分时间其实是合上的，
那我讲一线到一万，
其实我想说的是什么，
就是你现在对于一个产品，
你如果不在它的身体体系内，
你更多的直讲体验，
那么你如果是直讲体验，
其实硬件是一方面，
系统就是另外一方面，
无非就这两点，
硬件你觉得说不拉跨，
主流的硬件，
然后体验如果你对它的这套系统，
你也使用过，
或者说是你在网上会看各种评测，
你觉得这些功能啊，
包括用过一两年之后的丝滑程度，
你都能接受，
那完全可以买，
是不是，
价格差个几百块有无所谓的，
这个无非就是买手机的逻辑，
那买汽车呢，
买汽车其实也是一样的，
那么消费者其实现在买新的原车越来越懂，
我跟有些中端的经销商也经常会聊天，
销售顾问有的时候都没客户懂，
他们销售经理包括他们的销售总监，
看到那个销售顾问跟客户聊天，
直腰腿，
为什么直腰腿啊，
因为现在很多买新的原的年轻客户啊，
他们在网上已经了解的非常非常清楚了，
甚至于他们其实完全可以不用到店里面来，
他们就在网上直接下个单就可以了，
所以现在的CS店更多的变成那个什么，
叫体验中心，
所以为什么现在你像华为叫做什么用户中心，
对不对，
你像我今天就是参加了我们南京这边的，
就是华为卡斯门店，
就是华海的这个开业，
我当时也很纳闷，
我说这个店不是之前就已经开过业了，
怎么又开业了，
后来我才知道，
因为它每家店的规模和定级不一样，
定位不一样，
有的只能卖这个鸿蒙这几届，
不能卖尊介，
但是有的呢，
它规模或者它的这个等级到了这个位置，
它就可以卖尊介，
对吧,
它就是一个一个级别往上走，
然后呢，
规模变大了，
然后同时它的这个相关的服务体系，
也变得更加的全了嘛，
因为南京的这个华为的，
就是这个就是家居生态，
应该叫智能家居，
也是这个华海代理的，
然后我们南京侨北的那一家代理商叫，
叫欧亚还是叫什么，
基本上南京，
应该七八成以上的这种华为的，
叫做应该怎么说呢，
叫商场体验店，
就是卖这种华为的什么电脑啊，
耳机啊，
这些平呃，
派的呀，
这个平板，
都是那家经销商，
所以那个经销商是跟华为时间非常非常久的，
它现在在南京的江北开了一家店，
也规模非常的大，
现在这两家店竞争很激烈，
非常非常的激烈，
那么这次南京这个店开业是把那个海清请过来，
我们南京的走出去的一个女明星嘛，
海清,
所以今天我是近距离看到了海清啊，
明星啊，
这个这个我还是有点点这种最新的小心态的，
我再看哇，
这个名人啊，
然后我再看他的这个，
我上网查了一下，
我说他多大岁数啊，
怎么感觉保养的特别好，
七七年的，
我朋友圈我也在发，
我微博也发了一个视频，
七七年这种皮肤的状态，
整体的这种形象气质，
哇的天哪，
我就在想说明星怎么保养的那么好啊，
我不知道有什么诀窍啊，
要讲点题外话，
我们再拉回来继续讲，
那么今年，
其实消费者已经在这个时间节点越来越懂了，
那么他们去车展上去看，
他们会问，
说哎这个车带不带激光雷达，
带几颗激光雷达，
啊然后呢这个激光雷达，
为什么要放在这个位置啊，
为什么不放在车顶上啊，
啊为什么要放车顶不放在两边啊，
他会问很多专业问题，
包括电池啊零德时代的还是比亚迪的，
还是激光达的还是国宣动力的，
他会问啊你包括你为什么用他们家的，
就啊你为什么不用零德时代的，
对不对，
你用的是什么样的一个充电方案啊，
你支下方案是用的哪家的，
你充电速度怎么样啊，
你算力怎么样啊，
你但凡有一个问题回答不上来，
我说句实在话，
这个消费者把你的这个专业度评判，
我估计这个分数打的就会非常的低，
因为这是最基本的内容啊，
对不对，
你要如果说这车子你几颗芯片，
酸力是多少你都收不上来，
那你怎么卖车呢，
这跟我们当年去卖游车真不是一个概念，
完全不是一个概念，
我们当年卖游车，
长框高轴距发动机的功率扭距，
对不对，
变速箱基本的一些常识了解清楚，
这台车已经能去跟客户捞到半天了，
剩下来不就是一些配置单的东西吗，
但是现在这个里面差别太大，
太大了，
对不对，
所以说这个消费者其实影响他决策的东西，
随着他对于车的了解，
程度越来越高，
可能某一个点对他有一点出动，
他可能就把这个车的购买的权重比。
就调的非常高了，
所以现在可以这么讲，
就是在北京车展上，
零部件的展区已经不是那种可有可无，
或者说是北京车展的一个附属品，
附账品，
那么现在这些零部件的供应商，
可以说是十打十的技术代言人啊，
是消费者去买这个品牌的时候，
第一个要看到的，
就是这些技术代言人到底有哪些，
他们到底给你提供了什么样的一些技术，
这个是最关键的，
就有点像现在买笔记本，
你第一反应就是你到底是选英特尔，
还是选AMD嘛，
对吧,
这个是最确定的一件事情，
你要选英特尔，
那AMD的这一系列型号你就不看了，
是吧,
那么很多人买车，
其实现在真的不是充着标准的，
那就是充着电池，
充着它的芯片，
充着它的支架系统去的，
所以说今年的北京车站关于临部建制一块就聊那么多，
我觉得真的是非常非常的重要，
一定要去看，
这个非常关键啊，
那前面呢，
我们聊了那么多啊，
主要就是关于北京车站，
我觉得今年的最大的一个变化，
不仅仅是规模变大了，
新车变多了，
更关键就是他把这个供应商放到了台前，
而且话语权，
权重笔都变得越来越重了，
不仅仅是在行业内，
他的话语权变重了，
那实实在在的就是消费者买车，
也是真的把这些供应链体系的，
有品牌的，
也越来越认可，
对吧,
那我们接下来讲的呢，
我觉得还不是新车，
我觉得真的新车有机会，
我们后面在节目里面，
我们单独，
比方说十万二十万三十万五十万的，
我们就一个一个的去聊，
今天我想讲的就是，
你要如果去看车站，
你要如果是以新能源车为主的话，
那你一定会关注到，
第一个是支架，
第二个是置仓，
那么这两个东西到底怎么看？
今年北京车站呢，
我觉得支架这件事情啊，
四个字就能总结，
叫做顶天立地，
什么叫做顶天立地呢？
这个立地啊，
它就是普及，
就是让，
不能说是所有人吧，
就是让绝大多数的人，
都能用多少支架，
那有人讲说绝大多数之前那个，
比亚迪不是天神之眼，
已经基本上都普及了嘛，
天神之眼普及，
其实还没到更便宜的，
什么叫更便宜的，
就是一台不到十万块钱的车，
给你配上车位到车位的领行辅助，
有人讲说可能吗？
有这种车吗？
怎么没有呢？
以前可能没有，
但是现在有了，
就是零跑的那个A10，
这两天我看到也有不少人，
在知识星球后台私信我，
包括其他平台，
有人也是评论区私信问我，
说领跑A10这个车怎么样？
我一开始也没太在意，
因为什么呢？
因为领跑的车本身就比较便宜，
而且它的这个配置嘴额也比较高，
但是实际用起来怎么样？
其实说实在话，
包括它的这个，
比方说激光力达上车之后，
但是支架的功能很多都没开放，
所以我觉得这家车旗是，
你可以讲它是硬件郁埋，
舍得给你配置，
舍得给你下血本，
你也可以讲这家企业，
其实怎么说呢？
就是它在用户体验这方面，
它是非常非常卷，
就是我先给你把硬件卷上去，
软件慢慢叠带，
你不要着急，
包括它早期其实对于它自由的品牌，
就是领跑这个品牌的调性，
它也不是特别的讲究，
包括这台车子的，
不管是用料啊，
包括做工啊，
材质啊，
底盘质感啊，
操控啊，
在我看来，
它其实基本上它的要求就是，
六七十分吧，
而六七十分吧，
它不会说在某一个方面给你卷到极致，
它的核心目标就是要把整体的成本降低，
要把这台车肉眼可见的性价比得卷上来，
其实就这么简单一个事，
所以我觉得A10这个产品，
它很有代表性，
就这个车子当时一上市两天大定，
是多少？
大定破万，
两天大定破万还算可以了，
因为你想这个级别的车辆，
在小车市场上卖的好的一个月五六万台也有，
什么吉利新院啊，
比亚迪的海沃啊，
那么在网上像什么海豚这些车，
其实你玩来玩去都是那些品牌比较大的，
就是比亚迪或者是武林啊或者是吉利啊，
因为像这种级别价格不是特别高的十万以内的车型，
老百姓要的是确定性，
那么如果你的配置大杀不差，
然后空间啊也大杀不差，
续航也大杀不差就三百多四百多，
那在这种情况下的话，
我为什么不去买个大品牌呢？
对不对，
所以林跑在跟比亚迪跟吉利，
甚至跟武林去对标的时候，
它就稍微会吃点亏，
但是现在如果在智能驾驶这一块，
它就已经能够说，
不能叫降维打击吧，
就是最起码它给人感觉就不是在一个层次上了，
就是我给到的这个东西跟别人不一样，
那即使哪怕我现在慢慢的去给你开放，
给你去OTA相关的功能，
那别人也会觉得说至少它有啊，
是不是，
所以这个价格就不是相不相的问题，
我觉得这个价格定的是有点吓人，
啊有点吓人，
老百姓其实你说他要不要支价，
有人讲说啊其实他根本就不要支价，
他真的不要吗，
你送他你看他要不要，
还是觉得贵啊，
还是觉得这些支价，
要么就是在更贵的车型上去配备，
要么就是你动不动还要让他去花钱，
是不是，
你想花为的支价不就是嘛，
还要再花花钱，
虽然给你个卷，
还要再花八八块钱，
所以说，
大多数老百姓都是希望能够在十万啊，
十五万以内能够享受到更好的支价，
这是一个很朴素的愿望，
所以林跑现在就是说，
那不仅仅是把这个配置下放，
他其实也是跟行业表达一个态度，
什么态度呢就是，
大家不要再去啊，
去去想着说，
靠支价去一价，
不可能，
不用想了，
比亚迪打的是第一枪，
我觉得林跑打的是第二枪，
就是支价这个东西啊，
其实今后就跟什么一样，
就跟车上的空调，
音响一样，
他就应该是个标配的东西，
大家想一想是不是，
很快,
用不了多久，
支价就应该是标配，
大家还记得以前，
像什么肥毒啊，
质炫啊，
那个年代，
他还不在ESP车认稳定系统，
很多人还能忍，
为什么能忍啊，
他要的就是确定性啊，
就是油耗比较经济，
车子买回来比较保值，
空间也比较大，
然后国产车他又不信任，
所以你要如果没有ESP，
那我就忍一忍了，
现在你能忍吗，
你同样这么多的钱，
你根本就不可能忍的，
什么没有ESP啊，
你有多远滚多远，
是不是，
所以我告诉你，
用不了几年，
你再去看一辆行动原车，
有没有智能驾驶，
你是不是什么车位到车位的，
甚至于你有没有激光力达的智能驾驶，
你都会有要求了，
他就应该是标配，
但凡这个级别里面出现一款，
其他的必须给全部跟进，
必须全部跟进，
那么刚讲的是立地，
我们再讲顶天，
顶天是什么呢，
这一次车展上，
华为其实干了一件事情，
他是在车展直接宣布，
L3级的自动驾驶，
商用元年来了，
注意啊，
这里没有用到辅助驾驶啊，
是直接说的自动驾驶啊，
我们讲自媒体现在都是很谨慎，
一般讲到智能辅助驾驶，
都是要把辅助这两个字一定要着重，
甚至于有的人就不说智能了，
都会说是他配备的是高阶的辅助驾驶，
他直接把智能两个字去掉，
因为都在回避风险，
车企也不敢担这个责任，
只要不是L3，
基本上只要出问题，
还是你的人为操作的问题，
我又没让你说完全交给他来开，
是不是你还是一个辅助，
你要自己去手握方向盘关注路况吗，
但是这个L3级是什么概念，
L3级就是那个传说中可以合法的脱手脱脚，
什么意思，
其实一听就懂，
就是你不用再去手扶方向盘，
也不用再把脚放在油门跟煞车上，
应该叫电门跟煞车上，
是吧,
那么今后甚至于可以让你转移视线，
这都是合法的了都没有问题了，
只是说今后啊，
我讲的是今后，
就是L3级真正实现商用的时候，
那么更关键是什么，
华为这一次他不仅仅是讲到这个技术马上就要上了，
而且他会告诉你后面的责任问题，
他也会兜底，
什么意思呢，
华为当然是这么讲的，
他说在系统激活的状态下，
如果出了交通事故，
责任由华为跟合作的车企共同承担，
所以你要记住这里面有个前提条件，
就是在系统激活的状态下，
那么有人可能要讲，
说这个系统激活，
是不是我想用的时候，
我一下楼我就可以把它激活，
那么根据我查了一些资料，
我个人分析下来，
因为现在目前我没有人试到过L3级的商用的车型，
就是量产的车型，
我估计大概率是你看到了某一个路段，
然后他发现这个路段整体的，
不管是从路面跟车辆，
我们讲V2X包括车辆自身的这个条件，
他都能就是完全实现L3了，
那么他会提有一个提醒，
就是这个时候你可以激活L3，
所以这个L3不是你想什么时候激活，
就能什么时候激活的，
他是在有一定的限制条件下，
触发了之后就可以激活，
而且激活也不一定都是一直能用，
可能就是在这一段路上，
你比方说大概率，
他肯定是在某一段高速上，
这段高速是试点的L3的一个高速，
那么在这一段从A点到B点，
好比说25公里，
或者说是50公里，
那么他就提醒你你可以激活，
你只要一激活你什么都不用干了，
对吧,
但是你仔细想想看，
数据实在话这个，
现在很多的车子在高速上，
你真的还舍负方向盘，
脚放在油门踏板上，
电门踏板上，
实现不转移吗？
但是我不主张啊，
我作为一个就是，
这个怎么样呢，
就是这个正轮到主播，
我还是要跟大家讲，
方向盘一定要辅，
视线不要转移，
因为他毕竟目前大家买到的车，
都是辅助驾驶，
但我只是想说这么的现象，
肯定是有人在高速上，
开了辅助驾驶之后，
对吧,
你是实现是有转移的吗？
所以L3刚开始，
你不要期望说有颠覆式的变化，
那么到往后，
它陆陆续续的可能就变成了，
城市的这个绕神公路，
那么再往后才会到，
真正的城市的市区的复杂路况，
它就会告诉你，
这个地方也是能激活L3的，
你也可以让它去接管了，
那个时候才是大家心目当中的，
真正的自动驾驶，
对不对，
所以现在呢，
很多的这个辅助驾驶，
大家其实，
就怎么讲呢，
它不是不好用，
它是不敢用，
就是99%的情况下，
我知道你都很好用，
可是万一的1%发生在我身上，
这个车要是撞了，
要是蹭了，
要出了什么事故，
甚至包括大事故，
这个责任到底是谁的？
那么现在它告诉你，
就是在L3级的自动驾驶，
开始商用化的时候，
你买了我L3级的，
这个合法合规的车辆，
并且是在系统激活的状态下，
你只要用，
这个事情我来斗底，
所以你看啊，
一边我们讲是立地，
就是零跑A10，
它是把高阶支架，
直接摁在地上了，
就是告诉你，
今后这个东西就是标配，
这个东西今后就应该是人人都能用，
然后另一边我们讲就顶天，
像华为，
华为说我L3，
我直接把责任跟风险，
我个人来扛，
我扛起来，
你只要敢买，
我就敢去承担责任，
让有钱人敢放手，
因为第一批车子肯定是贵的，
而且今年发的这些牌照，
什么吉胡啊，
对吧这些牌照，
这些牌照他们一定会第一批量产，
就是这几个，
已经能够合法上路的车型，
所以你想买什么车，
你也没那么多选择，
就那么的一些品牌，
就那么的一些车型，
所以为什么我讲是，
一个是，
我们叫立地或者叫落地，
对吧,
还有一个叫顶天，
两条线同时再往前推，
所以这就是今年支架的一个大的变化，
大家注意看，
以后也是往这两个方向去走，
所以现在如果，
还有一些车型，
你手上如果没有那么高阶的，
你没有拿到L3级的这个牌照的，
你还说我在往支架去做溢价，
想都不用想，
不可能的，
绝对不可能，
你拿支架说故事根本没有用了，
对吧,
但是你现在又走，
叫什么平民化，
像零跑这种打到10万以内，
你又不愿意造这样的车，
你又不愿意给这样的车子去配，
更高阶的支架，
那么这种车型，
日子会非常非常难过，
会非常难过，
你既不去普会，
你又不去把技术推到更高端，
你也拿不到牌照，
那这一批，
应该是早晚可能会被，
淘汰掉的车型，
所以大家可以自行往你去靠，
你看哪些车型是这样，
支架既不能去普会，
又不能从高端，
手上也没有技术的，
那么这是第一个，
第二个呢，
我们讲今年车展，
我觉得重点要关注，
就是我前面说的，
智能座舱，
今后真正能够让车企活下来的，
就是智能座舱，
或者换句话讲，
你可以这么理解，
就是相当于手机的安卓系统，
跟苹果系统，
它今后会重新定义这个座舱，
你仔细想一想，
当如果真的L3时代来临的时候，
如果当这个市场上，
我们现在讲叫新能源，
它的占比，
比游车要，
这个不叫要多，
高多少吧，
就是从30%-40%-50%,。
现在已经到60%，
等于是它们俩调了个个，
以前是新能源车少，
游车是占绝对主导地位的，
现在新能源车占到60%，
游车占40%，
好，我告诉你，
那么今后，
一旦要是L3级开始普技，
甚至将来一点一点，
往L4去发展的时候，
你想一想，
你都可以转移视线了，
你的手都不用扶方向盘了，
你的脚都不用在那两个板板上搭着了，
对吧，加速也好，
刹车也好，
都不用你管，
那我请问，
这个座舱还需要这么设计吗？
那肯定不需要这么设计了呀，
那座椅一定要完全朝前方吗？
不需要，
我横着坐，
我倒着坐，
都可以啊，
对不对，
那车内我还需要坐着吗？
我站着我跳个舞，
我健个身行不行啊？
每天一上班，
哎,
有些人喜欢健身的，
有人喜欢跑步的，
我车里安个跑步机，
对吧,
车子一边跑，
我人在车里跑，
不对呀，
你人在车里跑，
你跑得上班不就行了吗？
不,
我就要在车子里面跑，
对不对，
下雨下雪天，
我就在车里跑，
让车给我开到公司，
也不是不行，
甚至于有些人早上叫没睡好，
开车还要开一个小时，
我就在车里睡一觉，
我补个回龙轿行不行，
我就为了上班不迟到，
我到了公司门口，
我就把我的手机掏出来，
我甚至让手机自动打卡，
对不对，
我早上，
你甚至找个机器人给我背下楼呗，
机器人把你从床上背下楼，
把你车子自动打开车门，
把你送上车，
你躺在车子里面床上继续睡，
然后眼睛都没睁，
到了公司了，
公司9点打卡，
你8点55分车停到楼下，
正好在公司区域范围内300米以内，
你这个叮叮自动打了个卡，
你没迟到，
闹钟响起，
然后甚至于车上出现个机器人，
再给你报到工位上，
你报到工位上，
你总得醒了吧，
如果你说我报到工位上，
我都不行，
我让机器人帮我写代码，
帮我工作，
那为什么给你发工资呢，
哎呀这个事情不能想，
所以说这个智能压实也好，
这个居身智能机器人也好，
是不是好事真不好说，
真不好说，
反正不管怎么说，
今后我觉得这个智能座舱，
不是我们现在理解的，
就是能跟他说说话，
有几块大屏幕，
不是这个概念，
是整个座舱的设计，
全部都要重新推翻，
早几年我记得跟我们一个听友，
他是坐这个车内饰设计的一个设计师，
他跟我讲他说，
他们现在的老师就已经提醒他们，
就是你们不用再去身搬硬套的，
用我们以前的那些设计的准则，
或者说设计的一些这种老的逻辑了，
因为等到你们将来毕业了，
说这个汽车市场，
如果一旦要是自动化普及，
他早晚是要普及的嘛，
就是自动压实普及，
就整个的内饰设计，
就完全不是以前那套逻辑，
所以你们要发挥你们的创意，
所以现在你会看到很多稀奇古怪的内饰，
你会觉得说天马行空，
但是你要想到一点，
他们这些设计是在为以后，
车辆一旦要是自动驾驶之后，
去有这种前瞻性，
有这种设计的一种，
怎么讲呢，
就是大家都想去做定义设计的人嘛，
对不对，
所以以后不是这么个逻辑了，
AI大模型，
其实是把人和车的这种关系，
从司机跟工具变成了，
它其实更像是主人和管家，
或者说主人和助理，
但是我们讲那么多呢，
我觉得所有的这些变化，
它最先在哪些车型上能够感知得到呢，
主要还是旗舰车，
所以你会发现，
自主品牌现在是集体冲高，
就是大家没发现个问题，
就为什么每个品牌都想去造自己的酒系，
动不动这个品牌出了一个什么什么酒，
那个品牌出了一个什么什么酒，
你认为说，
真的市场上有那么多人需要大车子吗？
我觉得不是的，
你觉得说这些品牌真的有能力去Hold住，
这种旗舰车型的价格吗？
我觉得也不是的，
这些品牌的领导，
或者他们的这些工程师，
他们也不傻，
他们也都知道，
家用需求其实很多要不了什么六座七座，
要不了什么五米二，
什么三米轴距的这种大车，
但是有一点你要想清楚，
如果一个品牌，
它没有这个级别的旗舰车型，
它怎么把这些技术落地在这个车上呢？
它总不能说把它最新的质价，
对吧,
什么三颗六颗激光力达的这些技术，
最新的这个什么索尔芯片，
用在一个十几二十万的车上，
如果这个品牌只有十几二十万的车，
它它怎么办啊？
它连落地都没地方落啊，
我讲的对不对，
我刚刚前面说的是智能驾驶，
还有包括智能座舱，
这两样东西其实都要去落在一个载体上，
而这个载体它一定是个旗舰车型，
去落最新的技术，
你本管这个车有没有人买，
那么至少我得有，
是不是，
所以你会发现今年北京车载，
各大展台中间最显眼的位置，
那基本上停的都是，
至少是八以上的，
八系或者是九系，
这种中大型的，
或者说是大型的SUV，
那么你像理想R9，
今年也是最新款对吧，
那未来ES9也是发了没够久的新款，
那问界M9今年也是新款，
对不对，
还是V牌的这些什么长沉的，
这些都是最新的，
所以说，
几乎现在整个的国产新能源，
就形成了一个叫九系宇宙，
九系宇宙，
就是各家的车型连在一起连成一片，
那么集体冲高，
你会以为说，
是因为它想往这个高端市场去冲击，
想要去抢BBA，
其实抢BBA抢了多少年了，
也不是这一天两天的事情了，
也有人讲说是因为时间到了这个点了，
所以各家该出九系了，
我觉得到了这个时间点了，
这个逻辑是成立的，
但是并不是到了这个时间点，
这个品牌就一定要往高端上去冲，
而是你仔细想想看，
是现在那么多的技术，
包括三电的技术，
什么900V,5C,。
包括支架的技术，
什么索尔芯片，
什么1000多少TOPUS的算力，
然后包括我们前面讲的，
就是这个坐舱的技术，
它陆陆续续的就要去沉载在这些旗舰设计上，
是它有这个需要了，
所以一定要有这种旗舰车，
所以最近这两年你会发现，
什么九系，八系，一片混战，
那有的人看不上，
说哎呀，
这个品牌怎么能卖四五十万，
有的人觉得说，
冰箱，彩天，大沙发，
这滑里胡哨的东西，
我不要，
但是你不要，
不代表别人不要，
你知不知道，
30万以上的SUV市场，
其实自主品牌的份额，
已经超过一半了，
这什么个概念？
你想一想，
以前你舍多如果有个30来万，
你别说考虑国产车了，
你就是连盒子什么封点大众，
你都不会去看，
你30多万的预算，
你肯定是直奔BBA，
但是现在，
自主品牌就咱们的国产性能源，
份额已经超过50%，
这是什么概念？
就相当于是把BBA的这个传统的腹地。
直接撕开了一个口子，
就自主品牌直接就杀进来了，
就原来是你的地盘，
现在全部归我了，
原来是买你的客户，
所以以前我们讲说国产车一定要绝对的便宜，
一定要空间大动力好，
配置高，性价比高，
但是现在，
我们不需要靠这个去赢它，
就是说我们现在走的是新灯源，
智能座舱，智能驾驶这一块，
你BBA没有，
你就算是有，
那我认为你也是个杂牌，
所以现在用户可以这么讲，
只要是刮绿牌的，
用脚投票，
就是买咱们国内的新灯源，
中国品牌，
所以这个是非常有意思，
自主品牌这边打的是热火朝天，
甚至于其实现在也你看，
很少有人再去拿BBA做对比了，
早年刚开始，
你像理想还动不动去比一比什么奔之宝马，
拿它去举例子，
用它的什么车的大小啊，
动力啊，
各种碾压它，
是不是拿它出来做对比，
现在你看还有人去对比吗，
都没有人去对比，
为什么不对比啊，
因为他们心里面也很清楚了，
就没有什么人拿BBA再去跟新灯源去比了嘛，
是不是，
所以现在我觉得BBA也开始反击，
这也是今年北京车展特别好玩，
特别,
我觉得你值得一看的，
其他展台不用看，
你就看两个就可以了，
一个是奔驰一个是宝马，
就是BBA现在叫做，
不搞拿来主义，
什么叫拿来主义，
以前的拿来主义就是说，
原来全球车型拿过来，
在中国稍微加个长，
长轴版中国特供，
这已经是对中国消费者最大的尊重了，
但是现在完全不同了，
你看现在宝马的叫新时代的RX3，
新时代的RX3，
它不是说只针对中国市场加长啊，
它的操作系统是中国团队开发的，
它的支架系统是跟咱们国内的摩曼塔合作的，
隔壁的奔驰也是跟摩曼塔合作中国的专属方案，
就是支架方案，
因为中国路况跟国外它确实不一样嘛，
然后宝马的这个RX3 AI大模型，
它是跟阿里联合定制的，
所以你换句话讲，
这个车虽然还挂着宝马的标，
但是它的灵魂已经交出去了，
它的灵魂已经是中国制造了，
挂的是宝马的标，
灵魂是中国制造，
所以我觉得宝马的广告曲可以换成那个，
什么,
我心依然是中国心，
对吧,
这个我觉得特别适合宝马，
所以呢，
不仅仅是宝马，
包括奔驰也可以唱这首歌，
他们两个老大可以一起唱，
对吧,
我心依然是中国心，
这首歌太适合他们了，
现在奔驰GLC，
奔驰这C纯电也是一样的，
哇,
那个屏幕是越搞越大，
就完全奔土化了，
不用讲了，
对吧,
摩曼塔的方案，
然后电池毫无疑问，
肯定也是用了咱们国内的电池，
林德时代就这么几家嘛，
还能用谁的，
对不对，
所以说，
不管是奔驰也好，
宝马也好，
甚至包括奥迪也好，
奥迪不是A6跟那个华为合作，
乾坤之价，
A4也是乾坤之价嘛，
对不对，
他们马新能源车也会用，
他新能源车是用了哪家，
我还没去研究，
是华为的还是摩曼塔的，
反正100%是国内的，
就说白了，
他们现在已经非常非常清楚，
他们的策略，
就是智能化这件事情上，
不管是智能驾驶，
还是智能坐舱，
你要如果让国外原来的那个团队去研发，
像大众的那个就做的跟啥一样的那个操作系统，
你让他去研发，
那我估计，
可能有生之年那些CEO都看不到了，
所以你不如直接就让中国的团队进来，
或者说直接就让中国现有的技术直接放到车上，
行了嘛，
搞那么复杂干什么呢，
其实这句话我最想讲给保时捷挺，
保时捷太看重自己这个标了，
其实保时捷完全可以再做一个，
叫保时捷，
比方说green，
就是保时捷绿色，
这名字有点土啊，
反正你就大概知道这么个意思就可以了，
就在原先保时捷的展厅边上，
再开一个保时捷展厅，
然后这个保时捷展厅就完全是绿色的底子，
甚至于包括保时捷的标都可以是那种，
就是浅绿的，
就那个叫什么马卡龙色，
叫什么色来着，
就是那种很浅的，
低饱隔度的保时捷的那个顿标，
保时捷以前顿标是金光闪闪的嘛，
那相当于就是老派O的马里嘛，
你现在就保时捷的标，
就把它变成那种浅绿色，
多帅啊，
浅蓝色多帅啊，
对不对，
然后所有的保尔叶车型，
一比一的全部复刻过来，
然后呢，
加上中国的，
你比方说华为的座舱，
华为的支架，
红萌座舱，
华为的ADS，
无敌了，
真的无敌了，
你想想看保尔叶的马卡龙，
用上华为的支架，
用上华为的座舱，
我的天哪，
你敢想啊，
ADS5一上车，
红萌支架一上车，
对不对，
零德时代的电池一上车，
价格,
价格对吧，
你稍微一价格5万，
10万,
我觉得保时捷一价个10万，
我是能接受的，
就是你跟同级车型去对比，
续航啊，
支架啊，
动力啊，
我觉得都是OK的，
然后你比别人贵个10万块钱，
我10万块钱就买你个标，
怎样,
OK的,
因为我在想，
你今后本身我用车成本就很低啊，
然后如果说保时捷，
它要是再能实在一点，
就比方说保养的分用，
也能跟正常的电车一样，
稍微便宜一点，
比方说正常的，
去一年一次保养一次1万公里，
那说我个600块钱，
就正常的吧，
因为我AVTA就是5 600块钱，
你哪怕收个1000，
我能接受啊，
我能就，
钱还不是该你赚的吗，
为什么就一定要高高在上呢，
就担心去影响它燃油车的，
这个价值体系，
其实我觉得根本就不用担心，
你独立出来一个小标，
就像手机的一张附卡一样，
流量还是用的主卡的流量，
但是实际上那个附卡，
你可以老婆用啊，
老爸用啊，
都是可以的，
哎呦真的完全可以，
现在国内的这些车企，
不就是这么玩的吗，
这些包括BBA都是这么玩的嘛，
就是围绕中国用户，
以前是躺着挣钱，
现在就要想一个新的办法，
怎么样能够，
既不影响全球的价格体系，
同时又能在中国把钱挣到手，
那其实我刚刚这个方案，
不是挺好的吗，
是不是，
我们哪怕就是退一万步讲，
就是保时捷这个绿标啊，
就保时捷Green这个品牌，
它就是做失败了，
做失败就做失败了呗，
做失败了就慢慢的，
缩减业务，缩减业务，
停产停产，
对你的燃油车完全没有影响，
一点影响都没有，
保日捷的绿标，
战略失败，
发一个这个申请，
对吧,
就发一个公告啊，
保日捷绿标退出中国市场，
结束呗，
保日捷绿标Green退出，
又不是保日捷退出，
一点都不会影响，
对不对，
我是这么想的啊，
大家可以在评论区，
我们一起天马行空的讨论讨论，
我就挺有意思的啊，
但是呢，
这里面就存在一个问题，
就是,
如果说奔驰宝马奥迪，
甚至包括保日捷，
它用的都是，
中国公司提供的智能化方案，
都是中国的供应商提供的技术，
那它跟自主品牌能拿开差距吗？
拉不开差距了，
它跟鸿鸿智行有什么区别啊？
它跟那些，
用什么抹门塔的支架，
用什么，
这个这个索尔的芯片，
多少多少TOPS的酸力，
用什么什么车机芯片，
有啥区别？
没任何区别了，
那如果都没有任何区别，
它的品牌一价，
它能撑多久呢？
我刚刚讲的说，
我说保时捷贵个10万，
我的理解，
那你要想，
保时捷它能接受
只比国产品牌贵10万吗？
它可不是想说只贵10万啊，
它可能是想比你贵一倍啊，
但是你觉得贵一倍的可能性大吗？
你看看今年奔驰宝马的价格，
已经是调到什么程度了，
不是说调新能源啊，
是游车的价格都在调，
今年的奥迪A6的官方指导价，
相当于整体降了10万块钱都不止，
但是我想讲的就是它即使降10万，
实际上也就是它老款车型的正常的成交价，
只不过他们现在也很明白了，
我不用再去高高在上的去挂一个价格，
然后再让你去还，
我直接给你一棍子骂到底，
就是我给你的指导价，
就是你的成交价，
哪怕说你过来再去敲咪咪的药一点，
什么其他的折扣优惠的，
那就看各家经销商啊，
他管得严不严了，
据我了解目前鸿蒙智形是管得非常严的，
但是有些呢，
我觉得也不用管，
你比方像特斯拉全是直营店，
那要管什么呢，
他说卖多少就卖多少，
鸿蒙因为有加盟商，
大家对加盟商严格的一塌糊涂，
我当时听讲说，
第一次抓到是比方说你价格乱爆，
或者说你私下区让价，
是罚20万，
然后是第二次罚多少，
我记不得了50万吗，
然后连续三次，
好像是两个月内连续三次吧，
还是一个月内，
就直接把你经销商给停掉了，
就是直接停业真改，
如果你再犯旅教不改的话，
直接就勸退，
就是退网，
直接给你勸退，
而且鸿蒙，
反正华为系，
我觉得对经销商的权限非常大，
这个有机会我们再聊吧，
或者我看能不能我来请一个行业内的人，
我把他声音给变了，
给他加个变身器，
看能不能让他爆一些内幕，
哇，这里面真的非常非常的，
让我很吃惊啊，
让我非常吃惊，
包括人世的这种决策群，
竟然都在厂家手里面啊，
总经理厂家都能任命，
我的天哪，
你要知道这是经销商投钱加盟的店，
这不是厂家直营店，
这也不是什么厂家跟经销商一起来合营的店，
这就是经销商的店，
但是厂家它就是有这么大的权限，
为什么？
其实说到底，
就是能帮经销商挣到钱，
你能给经销商挣得越多，
那么你主机场的话语权就越大，
就这么简单的逻辑，
因为我当年什么样奥迪，
我太了解了，
对吧,
那奥迪那么挣钱，
那区域经理大区总过来，
那就真的是跟爷一样的，
那就各家经销商围着转，
各种请时请和请唱歌，
是不是？
好，我们再讲一讲，
这个今年北京市场还要看一个点，
但这个点可能相对专业一点，
就是说，
我们前面聊的很多都是消费者能看到，
能摸到的东西，
也就是我们所谓的讲，
你可以说是面子，
也可以说是这种体验上直接了当的东西，
但是,
这一次车产其实真正决定未来战局，
我觉得更多的是藏在底子里面的，
就是椅子的东西，
但是这个面子和椅子，
不是说我们讲给别人看的面子，
或者给自己用的椅子，
而是能决定今后的技术迭代，
包括今后，
因为你现在买车，
你怕的是背刺嘛，
你背刺无非就两样东西，
第一个价格背刺，
第二个技术背刺，
你刚买来，价格降了，
刚买来，技术升级了，
其实你仔细想想看，
价格背刺，
它也是技术背刺，
它为什么要降价，
就是因为这一代的技术，
很快就要被淘汰了，
它马上就要出新款了，
所以这个车就要降价，
所以讲到底最终还是看不见的东西，
决定了你的购买体验，
那么首先第一个就底盘，
底盘什么意思呢，
底盘现在其实是一种叫做饭式革命，
就是以前是传统机械底盘，
现在已经陆陆续续打已经看到很多车，
都是什么，
都是叫全线控底盘，
我看到现在网友还在争论，
说啊这个全线控底盘怎么怎么不好，
我告诉你，
不要再去争了，
没有任何意义了，
因为这是100%-1000%的一个趋势，
就是以前还有一些硬连接的桿子，
有一些机械的结构，
现在全部是被电信号替代，
就像什么呢，
玩游戏，
玩那个模拟器，
对吧,
你玩模拟器那个视频里面，
电视机里面的那个车子在往左走，
往右走，
实际上你的方向盘跟它没连接，
你只是一个游戏的方向盘，
那它为什么车子会往左往右，
你其实传播的都是电信号，
通过这个电信号去控制的嘛，
那么你就想一想，
今后L3、L4这种高级的自动驾驶，
一旦要是普及了，
它还需要那些什么硬连接的桿子，
什么机械结构嘛，
不需要了，
它就是全先控底盘，
那么除了什么全先控底盘啊，
现在更多的人，
也看到了一些大车上用的这个后轮转向，
是吧,
那么除了这些以外，
包括像比亚迪这次展示的这个车瓦闪冲，
它这个车瓦闪冲这次展示很有意思，
它搞了一个像什么冷冻舱，
就是它能泼水成冰，
然后那个舱内是零下30摄氏度，
旁边还给你挖了个小孔，
干嘛用呢，
就是你可以把手伸进去，
你感受一下，
里面是不是零下30度，
让车子动的那个表面的覆盖键，
全部都是那个冰冰渣子冰柱子，
然后现场给你看，
充电速度到底怎么样，
它想展示的就是，
它在这种就是零下30度的环境下，
它的充电速度跟其实常温几乎没有差别，
速度非常快，
所以我估猜啊，
比亚迪后期可能会大规模的在东北建战，
特别是在冬天的时候，
你在东北一建战，
然后你再用几辆车这么一展示，
那东北老铁估计就受不了了对吧，
你平时都是开着游车的，
一直是苦游车那么多年，
新能源车又不敢买，
那现在有个罩瓦闪冲，
如果在东北就跟加油站一样普及，
对不对，
往那边一停咔咔咔那个电就补上去了，
那管你什么零下20度30度，
你冬天掉电快掉电快就是了，
无所谓的，
东北老铁对吧，
穿个雕一下车，
直接把电给补上了，
在旁边雕根烟，
充电站是能雕烟的，
加油站不能雕根烟，
在充电站旁边雕根烟，
手动的值得对吧，
一夜还没抽完的那个车上的电已经充满了，
那你想这是什么体验的，
所以电车并不一定说完全不能在东北普及啊，
是吧,
就关键一个，
就是看它的续航里程到底有多长，
然后第二个就是看它的补能的速度到底有多快吗，
就这么简单，
是不是，
所以你会发现，
当年,
好像有那么几家用这个空气悬挂，
结果,
好像就同级别的，
甚至再往下一个级别的车，
全部都在用空气悬挂了，
然后现在你在看，
有一个车开始用这个限控底盘，
哎,
结果很快，
第二辆第三辆车也在用限控底盘，
然后仅跟着可能这个级别再往下一个级别的车，
也在用限控底盘，
为什么会这样，
为什么呀，
就是因为供应链啊，
供应链体系成熟了，
它的货能供入上了，
规模铺开了，
成本降低了，
瞬间就普及了，
所以以后啊，
你不要再去针什么限控底盘好不好，
伙伴转向好不好了，
这个产业它的趋势，
一旦达到了这样的一个量级，
再想退回去是不可能的，
那么对老百姓来讲也是好事，
而且每一个产业，
它其实就是慢慢的，
从一个小花骨朵，
然后一点一点，
长成一朵花，
但是它如果是一朵花，
它就只能展成一朵花，
它如果是一棵树呢，
你要中国去培养行人员，
就相当于就，
它不是培养一朵花，
它是培养一棵苍天大树啊，
甚至于它培养的是，
一个整个亚马逊森林啊，
它是一点一点从一棵一棵的树种起来，
然后一棵一棵长起来，
最后变成了生态的多样化，
哇，我觉得真的很有意思，
而且你看今年的北京车展，
它都是一整个集团军作战，
就是一整个品牌以前还分开来，
现在都不分了，
比亚迪比亚迪直接就几乎是包了一个展，
吉利吉利也是各品牌连成一整个展，
然后包括像齐瑞也是什么，
截图星图埃卡齐瑞体系，
也是一个展，
那大家都在一个大的展厅里面，
而且这么多的老外，
今年来了N多的老外，
我住的是北京那个叫什么港澳瑞士酒店，
就是跟那个很多大使馆靠在一起，
我住在那个酒店，
我感觉那个酒店老外比中国人多，
然后那天晚上去吃饭也特别有意思，
我约了两个北京的朋友，
他说就是去那个什么京八大楼去吃，
京八大楼他说很有特色，
然后去了以后他也很震惊，
我当时觉得也很奇怪，
我说这个这个饭店怎么这么急啊，
就是走路还要测身，
原来他跟我讲说这个饭店本身都是小桌子，
就是一般都是四个人，四个人一小桌，
但是他也是第一次见到，
说这个饭店竟然接了团餐，
就是那个大圆桌，
他把那个舞台前面，
放了大概四五桌还是五六桌大圆桌，
然后我们也不知道是什么客户那个粮菜已经上了，
然后过了一会儿陆陆续续又来了一波又一波的老外，
第一波老外我还不知道这是来干嘛的，
第二波老外一坐下来我就知道了，
是比亚迪请了很多的经销商，
因为那些老外一看那个肤色啊讲话各方面，
就不是一个国家，
然后穿的衣服就是比亚迪的带着logo的衣服嘛，
有的逛在胸牌上面也是BYD嘛，
所以呢我就知道了啊比亚迪安排的这些老外，
也是住在可能跟我差不多经的一个酒店，
那我那个酒店是安排的吉利的很多的经销商，
然后讲的都是那个俄语嘛我就知道了，
那吉利肯定是把俄罗斯的相关的俄语区的一些经销商的安排过来了，
所以今年的整个车展老外特别多，
所以在整个车展上，
厂家其实要展示的是自己的护程盒，
是自己的整个的这一套体系，
所以每一个品牌都是集团军区作战，
它的每一个品牌的定位不一样，
就是它每个品牌下的各个子品牌的定位是不一样，
而且它的技术的分布也不一样，
它要一次性展示清楚，
所以说白了北京车展其实是一个秀肌肉的一个舞台，
它跟广州车展不一样，
北京跟上海车展都是秀肌肉的一个舞台，
所以你看北京车展上你要如果没有技术，
你就是展示你的车，
但如果说你要是有技术，
那你就不仅仅是展示自己的车了，
我前面说了你像比亚迪那个展台那么大，
刚刚有一个什么零下30度去展示它的招瓦闪虫，
它能展示东西多了，
以前其实大家对于像比亚迪这种垂直整合，
就什么事情都自己做，
还有一些争议，
你看现在还有争议吗，
没有争议了，
你是想做但你做不了，
汽车行业，
理论上讲应该是要讲究专业分工的，
专业分工全球采购，
但是比亚迪现在你感觉他做的是什么，
他是反其道而行之，
他从电池，电机，电空到什么RGBT芯片，
大家还记得有段时间缺芯的时候，
比亚迪不缺芯啊，
比亚迪不但不缺芯，
他还给别人去供应芯片，
是不是，
所以他基本上就是核心的零部件都自己干，
有人觉得说你是闭门造车，
也对,
比亚迪如果不是闭门造车，
闭门造电池，
那其实也没零德时代什么事情了，
他当年就是因为比亚迪电池只是自己供应，
然后才让其他的一些电池品牌就起来了嘛，
所以他以前是有吃过闭门造车的亏，
但是你现在来看，
闭门造车是不是意味着效率低呢，
是不是意味着跟不上外部的最好的技术呢，
我觉得也不一定，
也不一定，
关键是看他的技术实力到底强不强，
而且在经历了很多的这种像包括像全球供应链的危机，
包括国外的一些供应商恶意抬架，
对吧，掌握或者是垄断上游资源，
大家其实越来越意识到就这种不安全感，
就发现像比亚迪这种垂直整合，
其实这种模式反而是有很深的一个互衬盒，
别人缺薪，别人缺电池，
别人涨价，别人停产的时候，
那比亚迪受到影响就是最小的，
所以在北京市场上，
他就要展示自己的这套系统化的能力，
所以你可以理解为比亚迪，
他相当于是从以前的一个全能型选手，
我现在变成了一个金牌教练，
他不是说自己要去下场，
他同时还要把他的这套训练体系，
装备体系，技术体系，
他要输出，有人要输出给谁啊，
那想要的太多了，
你看看比亚迪在全球建的多少场，
你看看比亚迪在全球建的多少个，
包括这个跟三电系统相关的，
包括跟电池啊这些相关的，
你看看他的这种核心技术，
就是对外输出的这种能力，
他当然不是说教诲别人叫什么，
教诲徒弟饿死师傅，
自言核心技术，
他是作为产品相外输出，
你可以用我的，
你可以跟我合作，
那并不是说一定要把你教会，
那教会了，
对吧，那就真的是教会徒弟饿死师傅了，
是不是，
所以大家可以把格局稍微打开一点，
就这次北京车展上，
我不知道大家去看的时候，
老外还多不多，
就是真的，
就是老外在看中国的行程原车，
那真的是就有点像这个。
刘老老进大官员那种感觉，
虽然我也知道，
很多人啊也会讲说啊，
你别这么吹，
国外其实什么什么什么AI，
人工智能做的比中国要好，
其实我跟你这么讲，
全世界就两个国家，
现在人工智能做的是最牛白的，
一个是中国，
一个就是美国，
欧洲那边现在也想绝，
那天我看到是谁讲的，
那天我看到知识星球有个人，
有个兄弟讲的，
他说,
说什么小红书上，
有人讲啊好羡慕德国人的生活方式啊，
这个什么假期比较多，
也不加班，
可以轻松享受生活，
然后那哥们儿讲说，
简直就是胡扯，
他说我要如果不是在一家，
就是全球性的公司，
那我还就就真就性了，
他说德国的那个团队，
那个分公司，
是整个他们全球公司效率最低，
是倒数第二还是倒数第三，
然后同时现在也是在卷啊，
也是卷加班，
也是卷KPI，
然后特别搞笑的就是，
那天我看到那个美国的一个哥们儿也在讲，
说美国这边硅谷也天天在喊996了，
呵呵,
美国的硅谷也天天在喊996，
马上都快要007了，
人家讲的很简单，
人家说这个时间点，
中国的这些AI公司，
灯都还没有关，
人还没下班，
那我们现在如果要是跟他赶进度，
赶速度根本就赶不上，
所以都在主动加班啊，
主动去玩火，
只不过可能有的人不是在公司干，
啊报个笔记本电脑就回家干了，
但是都在加，
全球都在卷，
没办法，
因为现在这个时代，
我觉得真的是一个，
怎么讲呢，
是一个是从能源上来讲，
就是一个人类历史转变的一个时代，
只不过他是在慢慢的演变和进化，
我觉得每一个人在这个时代，
就参与到这个环节当中啊，
虽然说有危机，
但是也有机会，
所以大家怎么讲呢，
还是要抱着那种拥抱未来的一种形态，
一定要去多多去了解一些新鲜事物，
你可以通过播客去了解，
你也可以通过文字去了解，
但是我建议就不要过多的通过小视频去了解了，
因为小视频你刷着刷着，
你就开始刷美女视频跳舞了，
知道吧，
刷着刷着你就想看那些更轻松的东西了，
你多去了解一些外部的世界，
多去掌握一些这种相关的技能，
你不要总是想着说啊，
AR来了以后怎么办啊，
工作淘汰了，
被替代了，
想办法融入它，
你对抗肯定是对抗不了的，
对吧,
想办法融入它，
想办法利用它，
老板也不傻，
老板也要看，
就同样的一个员工，
它的效率到底有多高，
当你能够熟练的使用这些AR的时候，
你会发现你效率在涨，
但是你也可以不用去分享给别人嘛，
你偷偷的在家研究嘛，
对不对，
老板觉得你做的又好，
文章写的公公整整的，
虽然通过了AR的优化，
然后表格整理的数据一个都不差，
哇,
老张老王做的表格你漏洞摆出，
数据全是错的，
你做的小数点进去到后18位，
那你想想看，
那老板喜欢谁，
那肯定喜欢你嘛，
是不是，
你还能预判老板的预判，
你可以通过AR做很多的事情，
我们这个讲的有点预言啊，
反正不管怎么说，
我觉得现在都是高维度的竞争，
都是高维度的竞争，
各家车企也是一样，
其实我们作为个人个体也是一样的，
就是你要如果说你有这种垂直垂直整合的能力，
你有自己的供应链的能力，
那你可以把它输出，
啊变成可以输出的这个品牌化的能力啊，
是不是，
所以现在你说车企在打什么战，
它根本就不是单点作战，
现在是体系化作战，
都是集团经在作战，
它是未来在全球生态当中，
它要去真话语权，
需要去真它的定价权，
所以顺着往下讲，
就我觉得不止比阿迪一家了，
因为现在整个的供应链都在品牌化，
它就是一个，
怎么讲呢，
就是供应链品牌化是一个非常突出的优势，
很多的一些车企宣传稿里面讲，
我搭载的是华为ADS，
我用的是林德时代的麒麟电池，
或者用的什么低频线啊，
这个那个的，
它都是用这些供应链，
去给它做技术背书嘛，
对不对，
但是就反过来讲也是，
我觉得整车厂车企非常焦虑的问题，
就是我前面说到的控制权的问题，
所以呢你回头再看，
咱们国内那吹着整合，
其实整个产业链都能说控制在自己手上的，
或者绝大部分，
控制在自己手上的，
真的没有几家，
前面我们讲的比阿迪算一家，
但是你看海外的就是最有名的那一家，
就是特斯拉，
那真的就是制造也在自己手里面，
芯片也在自己手里面，
系统也在自己手里面，
都在自己手里面，
所以它控制权就非常的强，
我们以前讲比方说制价，
有叫黑核交付，
就像早年吉利的那个mobile，
智能驾驶辅助系统，
就是说你不能改，
你不能升级，
全部都是由我来，
我是黑核交付，
像个黑色的盒子，
里面就打不开，
上了锁了，
现在叫白核交付，
什么叫白核交付，
就是你现在用不愿意跟我合作，
你想不想成为我的供应商，
想OK,
那我们两个人，
就一起来去研究，
那你要把你的一些底层代码交出来，
你要让我，
能够今后自己去自行升级，
自行OTA,
自行去跟我的这个，
车辆的这个底盘各方面的状况，
去进行适配，
所以现在都叫白核交付，
所以这里面也是个博弈的过程，
当然了高麦老百姓没什么关系啊，
这个也就不多讲了，
反正不管怎么说，
咱们今天聊那么多啊，
其实从北京车展，
它的规模到展台布局啊，
多少个展馆，
17个展馆是吧，
再到它的整个的，
从制价制仓，
再到高端SUV，
就是冲这个酒系啊，
然后再到BBA的中国式的反击，
然后到底盘补能，
供应链，
价格逻辑，
你会发现这里面有一条非常清晰的主线，
就是这一届的北京车展，
真正最重要的是什么，
不是它有多大，
不是它有多少台车，
不是它有多少场发布会，
而是现在整个汽车行业的游戏规则，
正在慢慢的改变，
而改变这个游戏规则的人，
其实就是你和我，
就是你手里面捧着这个钱，
钱去哪了，
消费者在买什么，
他们想要什么，
其实每一个主机场，
包括这些供应链的供应商，
都在削剑的脑袋去想，
怎么能让你把手里面这个钱，
口袋里的钱给掏出来，
买他们的产品，
认可他们这些技术，
那么其实中国整个的汽车产业，
它现在也是在做一个，
可以说是历史上非常重要的一次，
根本性的转向，
以前是讲谁卖的多，
谁卖的更便宜，
然后呢，
这个谁的性价比更高，
现在其实比的就是说，
谁定义这个产品，
定义的更准确，
谁的这一套，
智能化的体系更加的完善，
今后其实就延伸到生态了，
就是谁的生态的圈子，
让他觉得，
就是更加的想要融入，
那你就会选择这款车型，
或者说你会在这个生态体系里面，
选择它旗下的这一系列的车型，
就是这么简单一个事，
所以今后的竞争啊，
我觉得，
就是叫做，
有竞争，
又无竞争，
什么意思呢，
就是今后其实，
就是生态体系的竞争，
生态位已经确定好之后，
你再想争，
已经没有你的位置了，
就这么简单个事，
我觉得好戏啊，
也在刚刚开始啊，
大家也是拭目以待，
所以讲一千到一万，
今天很多都是分析行业力的事情，
我觉得作为普通消费者来讲，
换车啊，
不要太上头，
因为现在还是一个技术在不停迭代的过程，
如果说你今天买，
你担心明天就更新，
可能过个半年就更新，
你今天买担心过个半年就降价，
那我觉得你这个担心是多虑了，
是多余的，
为什么？
有人讲说，
是不是不会这样，
或者不升级，
不可能，
它不会以你个人意识而转移，
它一定会升级，
它一定会降价，
它一定不能讲是越来越便宜，
就是说它一定会同样的钱买到更好的东西，
就这么简单的道理，
所以不要奢望，
就是说买一辆车能够用很久，
然后一直感觉没被淘汰，
就像手机一样，
你现在买一个iPhone 17，
你看我这个iPhone 17，
壳子都没有划痕的，
马上iPhone 18都要到了，
那你说我怎么去想，
我纠结吗？
我不纠结，
因为我已经提前这么个半年，
或者说提前这么个几个月，
我已经享受到了，
而且本身这个功能，
我已经觉得够用了，
它起码跟我上一台手机比，
它的性能已经提升很多了，
这就可以了，
那18我不买，
19我不买，
等到iPhone 20 21,。
我再入不就行了嘛，
对不对，
好,
今天就聊那么多吧，
今天聊的有点多，
这个互动啊，
因为我中间节目出现了一点小状况，
所以有那么三期节目的互动，
都没有去跟大家进行留言抽奖了，
但是今天这一期聊的时间有点久，
而且时间有点晚，
我明天还要早起有点事，
嗓子有点哑，
所以找了这么多的理由，
就今天先不互动了，
没关系，
反正该是你的礼品，
肯定是不会少的，
下期节目，
我们就把前面这几期，
一起放到我们的节目的尾声，
然后进行互动，
每一期节目，
我们评论区都会抽三位，
赠送由认严计提供的。
预录相离，
非常的好吃啊，
是施装五颗一盒，
那么如果你想买的话呢，
也可以上小程序搜索摆车全说，
在我们的小程序里面就可以下单，
那么同时呢，
大家如果想关注我更多的原创内容，
可以上bdbd搜索摆车全说，
也可以在小视频平台，
抖音快手视频号，
还有包括小红书，
搜索三刀砍车，
单人旁砍大山的砍，
那么一击我的个人微博，
摆车全说三刀，
那如果想跟我一对一的交流的话，
可以加微信，
46415254,。
还有我们的公众号，
每天都会有更新，
叫摆车全说，
你要想进群，
或者关注我所有的这些原创内容，
其实公众号上都有，
好吧,
那么今天这期节目就到这里，
我们下一期，
接着聊，
拜拜!